>> Greg: NEW YORK STATE JUDGE
ORDERED A 30-YEAR-OLD MAN TO
CLEAR OUT OF HIS PARENTS HOUSE.
MICHAEL ROTONDO DIDN'T PAY RENT
OR DO CHORES.
BASICALLY HE IS A TINY VERSION
OF CONGRESS.
HE WAS SUED BY MOM AND DAD AFTER
HE REFUSED TO LEAVE.
SELF-EMPLOYED BUSINESSMAN, THE
PARENTS HAVE YET TO SEE ANY OF
MICHAEL'S SECRET SOURCE OF
INCOME.
I AM BEGINNING TO WONDER WHAT
THAT IS.
HIS PARENTS HOME WAS ACTUALLY A
SANCTUARY CITY.
AND HE REAPS THE BENEFITS,
APPARENTLY THINKING EVERYTHING
SHOULD BE FREE.
HE ALMOST QUALIFIES AS A
COMMENCEMENT SPEAKER OR AT LEAST
A VERMONT SENATOR.
AFTER A PILE OF IGNORED EVICTION
LETTER SOME OF THE JUDGE RULED
FOR MOM-AND-POP.
BEING GOOD PARENTS, THEY OFFERED
HIM MONEY TO HELP THEM FIND A
PLACE TO STAY AND FIX HIS CAR.
THEY ALSO GAVE HIM SOUND ADVICE,
INCLUDING "ORGANIZE THE THINGS
YOU NEED FOR WORK AND MANAGE AN
APARTMENT.
"AND "THERE WILL BE OTHER THINGS
THAT HAVE SIGNIFICANT VALUE."
THERE ARE JOBS AVAILABLE EVEN
FOR THOSE WITH A POOR WORK
HISTORY LIKE YOU.
GET ONE.
YOU HAVE TO WORK.
TRANSLATION: GET OFF YOUR BUTT
AND DO SOMETHING WITH YOUR LIFE.
NOW EVICTED, HE DID SEE HIS
PARENTS AFTER THE RULING AND
SAID IT WAS PRETTY AWKWARD PRINT
ON THE BRIGHT SIDE COME HE COULD
ALWAYS MOVE INTO A STARBUCKS.
>> Kimberly: THIS IS THE
PROBLEM.
THIS IS WHY I'M GOING TO
DUNKIN' DONUTS.
>> Greg: KIMBERLY, THIS GUY'S
ALL OVER THE NEWS.
HE'S GOING TO BE ON
MARTHA MacCALLUM TONIGHT.
I MOVED IN WITH MY MOM WHEN I
WAS 23.
I SAVED FOR A YEAR.
I THOUGHT IT WAS PRETTY GOOD.
THIS KID IS PUSHING IT.
>> Kimberly: HE IS PUSHING IT.
DIDN'T HE GO BACK TO THEIR HOUSE
AFTER THE JUDGE TOLD HIM TO GET
A LIFE AND GET A JOB.
KNOCK, KNOCK.
HE'S PROBABLY GOING TO FIND SOME
POOR UNFORTUNATE INDIVIDUAL WHO
WILL TAKE HIM IN.
HE'S GOT HIS 15 MINUTES OF FAME.
PEOPLE TAKING SELFIES WITH THIS
GUY.
WHEN THAT PASSES OVER COME I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IS GOING TO DO.
PROBABLY MOVE BACK IN WITH HIS
PARENTS.
WHAT KIND OF SELF-RESPECT DOES
HE HAVE?
HIS PARENTS ARE SO SWEET.
>> Dana: HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
GET A GIRL?
>> Kimberly: HE GOT ONE FOR A
SECOND, I GUESS.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT THE
SOLUTION IS, MOVEMENT AND BECOME
A BUTLER.
BECOME SOMEONE'S BUTLER.
BUT A BAD ONE, A LAZY ONE.
>> Richard: I THINK THE WORD
MILLENNIAL IN THE SCREEN BEHIND
ME.
>> Dana: THAT BOTHERS YOU?
>> Richard: I PACKED UP AND
WENT TO COLLEGE AND 18.
I WAS LIKE MOM, I AM NEVER
COMING BACK HOME.
YOU COULD ALWAYS COME HOME.
NO, I'M GOING TO GET A JOB AND
WORK AND THAT'S WHAT MY FRIENDS
DID AND WE ARE DOING GREAT AND
WE ARE ALL MILLENNIAL.
THEY WORK AND THEY HAVE THEIR
OWN APARTMENTS AND THEY DON'T
LIVE AT HOME WITH THEIR PARENTS
AND THEY PAY RENT.
>> Greg: THIS IS ON AN EARLIER
SHOW, ON THEIR NETWORK, I CAN'T
THINK OF THE NAME OF IT.
>> DO YOU NOT WANT TO FIND YOUR
OWN PLACE?
>> NO.
>> WHY NOT?
>> I DON'T WANT TO LIVE THERE
ANYMORE.
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO LIVE WITH
YOUR PARENTS?
>> NO.
>> WHY DON'T YOU MOVE OUT
TOMORROW?
>> I DON'T HAVE THE MEANS TO DO
THAT TOMORROW.
>> DO YOU HAVE A JOB?
>> NO.
>> DON'T YOU WANT TO RECONCILE?
>> Dana: I KIND OF FEEL BAD.
I FEEL BAD FOR EVERYBODY.
>> Greg: YOU DO.
HE IS DOING THE TV.
HE COULD HAVE MOVED OUT.
HE >> Dana: I THINK THE LURE
OF BEING ON TV, I WILL GO INTO
THE INTO MY STORY.
EVERYBODY, I'M SURE
MARTHA MacCALLUM WILL BE ABLE
TO GET MORE OUT OF HIM.
>> Pete: HE IS BAD AT BEING A
DEADBEAT.
HE WANT TO STAY AT YOUR PARENTS
HOUSE FOREVER?
MAKE THEM DINNER ONCE IN A
WHILE.
DO SOME CHORES.
DO A COUPLE CHORES.
THEN THEY GIVE YOU ANOTHER YEAR.
INSTEAD HE IS LIKE, I WILL DO
NOTHING.
YOU WILL HAVE TO EVICT ME.
>> Dana: IT'S A WEIRD THING
HAVING TO GO TO COURT.
>> Kimberly: WHY DIDN'T THEY
CALL THE COPS?
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD DO.
>> Dana: RONAN COMES HOME,
IT'S GOING TO BE OPEN ARMS.
>> Greg: I'M GOING TO DEFEND
HIM AND SAY BECAUSE WE ARE
LIVING LONGER, 31 IS THE NEW 13.
>> Dana: I AGREE.
>> Richard: I AM 31 AND I AM
NOT 13.
>> Greg: I BEG TO DIFFER.
LIVING LONGER.
YOU CAN STAY LONGER AT HOME.
>> Dana: IT'S A GOOD POINT.
WHAT IS THE ACCEPTABLE AGE?
LET'S SAY IT'S 25.
KIDS SHOULD BE ON THEIR PARENT'S
HEALTH INSURANCE UNTIL 25.
I DON'T SAY THAT BUT THE LAW
SAYS THAT.
26.
30.
MAYBE YOU ARE RIGHT.
>> Greg: I AM FOR CLOSE
FAMILIES, MULTIGENERATIONAL
FAMILIES.
ALL RIGHT, OKAY, THEY ARE